[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وكل عام وانتم بخير سعد
النظام السوري وحليفه الروسي عملياتهم
العسكريه ضد المعارضه تزامنا مع بدء سريان
الهدنه التي تم التوصل اليها بين
الامريكان والروس تزامن ذلك مع تصريحات
سياسيه من جانب الرئيس السوري ومسؤولين
روس تؤشر الى عدم التعامل بجديه مع الهدنه
التي بدات بالفعل مساء اثنين وانتهك
النظام على الفور نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ل
نناقشه في
محورين ما هي احتمالات صمود الهدنه في ظل
التصعيد السياسي والعسكري من جانب
النظام وما هي خيارات المعارضه في مواجهه
التفاهمات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه في سوريا ساعه هدنه وساعات حرب
بعد توصل موسكو وواشنطن الى اتفاق هدنه
هناك لا تبدو الامور على الارض مبشره عد
النظام ومعه الحليف الروسي عمليتهم
العسكريه وبينما كان العالم ينتظر سكوت
المدافع ينتهك النظام هذه الهدنه في
ساعاتها الاولى بل ويخرج الاسد من داريه
متحدثا عن حرب لن تنتهي قريبا تصريحات
تتزامن مع اخرى روسيه تفرغ الهدنه عمليا
من مضمونها فيما يتعلق بمساله حذر الطيران
تقرير ناصر اي طاهر
الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر الرئيس الواثق
المطمئن او الرئيس المسيطر على الاوضاع
هذا ربما ما يراد
ت ولعل بشار الاسد فعلا كذلك على الاقل
هنا في داريه التي خلت له من اهلها ودون
نبره تصعيد لن تكتمل حبكه العيد القوات
المسلحه مستمره بعملها من دون تردد ومن
دون هواده وبغض النظر عن اي ظروف داخليه
وخارجيه في اعاده الامن والامان الى كل
منطقه في
سوريا لما يكون التهجير الممنهج ثمنا
لعوده ذلك الامان قد يسمي النظام الامر في
بري دمشق هدنه مع ان له تاريخا اسود في
نقض الهدن انه استخفاف بالاتفاقيات قد
يفسر وعيد الاسد في هذا الظرف بالذات
باستعاده كل الاراضي السوريه
بالقوه حتى لو كانت مناوره سياسيه من
النظام فقل ان تجد بين السوريين من عاد
يثق في الهدن
السياسيه منهم من بدت لهم الهدنه الاحدث
التي هندسها الامريكيون والروس غير قابله
للصمود قوات الاسد وتلك المتحالفه معها
وفرت للمتشائمين سريعا ما يدعم تشاؤمهم
حدث هذا قبيل ساعات من بدء سريان الهدنه
ففي ريف حمص الشمالي وفي حلب تكثف قصف
طيراني الاسد وموسكو على قرى وبلدات خاضعه
لسيطره المعارضه كما ان جبهات عده غير هذه
تشتعل منذ يومين انها بذلك تضع علامه
استفهام كبيره امام مصير هدنه تنص بنودها
على وقف ما تسمى بالاعمال العدائيه
والسماح بادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المناطق المحاصره لكن تجربه الهدن السابقه
تنبئنا باستراتيجيه النظام السوري
المتنسبه وحلفه الروسي على استهداف مناطق
المعارضه بحجه مكافحه الارهاب مع ان ما
يسمى الارهاب تحصره الهدنه الحاليه في
فصيلين كما يسعى النظام خلال الهدن غالبا
الى توسيع م سيطرته وتقليص تلك الواقعه في
ايدي المعارضه
المسلحه كانما هي مسابقه للزمن لحصد اكبر
قدر من المكاسب وايقاع اكبر ضرر ممكن في
المعسكر
المقابل والحقيقه ان المفاوضات العسيره
التي افضت الى اتفاق جنيف والاخفاقات
السابقه في الالتزام بالقرار الدولي الخاص
بوقف الاعمال العدائيه تغذي شكوكا كثيره
في صمود الهدنه دعك عن تفضي الى مسار يعجل
بالحل السياسي في سوريا حتى ان التشكيك
بالنوايا الامريكيه والروسيه كان مطروحا
على الطاوله فالمعرض السوريه بجناحيها
السياسي والمسلح لم تتم استشارتها قبيل
الهدنه ولم تمنح ضمانات تتعلق بتطبيقها زد
على ذلك ان موسكو هي احد ابرز حكام
الاتفاق وهي في الاساس خصم للشعب السوري
كثيرا ما بادرت هي نفسها ب انتهاك اتفاقات
وقف النار اما اختلاف اولويات واشنطن
وموسكو فمس اله اخرى يخشى ان تعوق حسن سير
الهدنه محاربه تنظيم الدوله اولويه
امريكيه بامتياز تترافق مع ما يعتقد انها
محاوله لتجميد الصراع بين النظام
والمعارضه اما روسيا وحلفها في دمشق
فالمعارضة محاربه تنظيم
الدوله نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من باريز
عبد الناصر العايد الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي السوري ومن واشنطن اندرو
تابلر كبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن
لسياسات الشرق الادنى والمتخصص في الشؤون
السوريه ومؤلف كتاب في عرين
الاسد نبدا من واشنطن والسيد اندرو
تابلر هل تعتقد بان هذه الهدنه
التي اعلنتها واشنطن وموسكو قادره على ان
تصمد في حين لم تصمد هدن اخرى في السابق
في
سوريا هذا سؤال
جيد النص لم يتم اعلانه ونشره لذلك من
الصعب ان نحكم عليه لكنه اختبار للروس هل
يمكنهم ان يجعلوا نظام الاسد يتوقف عن ضرب
المعارضه وهل ايضا يمكن للامريكيين ان
يقنعوا المعارضين ان
يهاجموا النظام اذا سبعه ايام القادمه
ولكن بدايه هذه الساعات الاولى لا تبشر
بخير في الساعات الاولى
ايضا كيري بدا في مؤتمره الصحفي الاخير
متفائلا نوعا ما رغم ان البدايات لا تبشر
مثل ما ذكرت على اي اساس تعتقد انه يبني
مثل هذا التفاؤل
اعتقد ان هذا
رايه هو يعرف
محتوى الاتفاق ونحن لا نعرفه وربما هو
يعتمد على محادثاته مع روس سوف نرى ان كان
الروس سوف يلتزمون ببنود الاتفاق مع
الولايات المتحده
ح مثل ما ذكرت البدايات لا تبشر بخير سيد
عبد الناصر
العايد يعني بمجرد ما بدات الهدنه بدات
الخروقات ومن النظام تحديدا كيف يمكن ان
نفهم
ذلك بعتقد هي الخروقات يعني لن تكون مجرد
بدايه وهذا هو النهج الذي سيستمر لكن
بالتاكيد يعني انا لدي راي في هذا الموضوع
انه الامريكان
فرضوا نزع نزع السلاح او توقف العمليات
بما يخص مدينه حلب المحاصره وفتح طريق
الكاستيلو ولن يطالبوا باكثر من ذلك يعني
والروس يعرفون هذا ويعرفون انه يعني يجب
ان يوقفوا هجمات النظام وان يفتحوا طريق
الكاستلو في الايام السبعه القادمه
وبمقابل ان تطلق يدهم في بقيه المناطق في
ريف حلب وفي منطقه ادلب و وغيرها وهم يب
يبداون عملهم هذا بكل يعني بكل
بساطه كيري يعرف جيدا انه
الروس يعني
اي في حاجه ماسه الى عقد اتفاق معهم وعمل
تعاون عسكري معهم هو الاتفاق رهنه بسبعه
ايام تثبت خلالها روسيا مصداقيتها اعتقد
انه في طريق الكاستلو في موضوع مدينه حلب
سيتم الايفاء بالتعهدات الروسيه رغم ما
شهدناه اليوم من قصف على الشقيف وغيرها
هذه استكمال لعمليات النظام الاجراميه
التي يعني ربما كان قد بداها مسبقا لكن
سيتم الالتزام بهذه الجزئيه بالمقابل
سيصبح بامكان الطيران الروسي ان ان يتقد
ان ان يزيد من عملياته وزخمه في كل
المناطق بوتيره اعلى و وهو يامن ال ال
المحاسبه الامريكيه تحديدا يعني هو كان
دائما يتخوف من انه يكون
المسؤوليه وحيده عليه في المنطقه وان
تستغل الولايات المتحده انتهاكاته وما الى
ذلك هذا بعد عده ايام من عقد الاتفاق وبعد
ان يعني تجلت كروج بالفعل اتضح شكل
الاتفاق النهائي انه تبقى حلب
المحاصره لا لا يتقدم اليها النظام وطريق
الكاستيلو يبقى يعني من شريان باتجاهها
بالمقابل الروس يحصلون على في حال ثبتت
مصداقيه هذا الامر يحصلون على تعاون امني
عسكري مع الامريكان هذا طمح اليه كثيرا
ويعني فعلوا كل ما بوسعهم للحصول عليه ذ ح
سيد سيد العايد على ذكر حلب هناك وجهه نظر
تقول هناك وجهه نظر تقول سيد تابلر بان
الامتحان بالنسبه لهذا اتفاق
الهدنه سيرتكز على نقطتين حلب من ناحيه
وادخال المساعدات من ناحيه اخرى هل تعتقد
بان هذا هو الامتحان الحقيقي كبدايه لهذه
الهدنه اعتقد ان ذلك هو الرهان الولايات
المتحده تحقق تحسن في حلب في الاسباع
السبعه ايام الاولى والقسم الثاني في
ايجاد مركز
لمحاوله وهذا ما ارادته
واشنطن وسوف ترى ان كان الروس سوف يحترمون
وعودهم في السبعه ايام الاولى لتخفيف
معاناه الناس في حلب ولكن سيد تابلر يبدو
ان الامريكيين يتعاملون مع هذه الهدنه
وكانها امتحان للروس وليس امتحان للنظام
او امتحان لاي اطراف
اخرى هذا صحيح اعتقد انهم يختبرون
الروس لوا الى اي مدى
النظام يستمع
للروس ان لم يكونوا قادرين على جعل النظام
يلتزم
هناك تقدير للخروقات سيد العايد هناك
تقدير للخروقات في الهدنه السابقه في
فبراير شباط الماضي تم توثيقها ب
3200 خرق للهدنه
هل تعتقد بان فتره اسبوع كافيه للحكم على
هدنه تقف على رجليها ام
لا لا لا بالتاكيد وكل الاطراف تعلم ذلك
يعني هذه المساله معقده جدا ومتداخله جدا
يعني انا اختلف مع وجهه النظر تقول انه
الامريكان يختبرون الروس ويريدون ان يعني
يتاكدوا ليتقدموا خطوات الامريكان ليس هذا
هدفهم الامريكان هدفهم تجميد حاله الصراع
باي اتفاقيات تيكيه جزئيه مرحليه مؤقته
موضعيه بحيث انه يتم تسليم هذه القضيه
بقضها وقضيضها وبكل ارتها للحكومه القادمه
الاداره الامريكيه القادمه العمليه عمليه
محاوله تجميد صوره الصراع يعني قدر
المستطاع باقل الخروقات لاستراتيجيه يعني
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه اللي هي اداره
التوازنات
لانه ما ما بتصور انه التعاون الامريكي
الروسي ايضا يعني عدا انه الروس ما راح
يلتزموا الاتفاقيه كما يجب باستثناء كما
ذكرت انت يعني هذا الشيء الذي يركز عليه
الامريكان عدم حصار حلب وعدم مهاجمه مناطق
المناطق المحاصره وال ايصال المساعدات
لانه حلب هي بارومتر الصراع هي المؤشر
الرئيسي للصراع فما بدهم صير تغيرات كبيره
حول حلب استراتيجيه كما قلت لتسليم الملف
بشكله الحالي الى الاداره القادمه لكن
ايضا هناك مساله اخرى انه الامريكان لا
يمكن ان يذهبوا بعيدا في مساله التعاون مع
الروس وقد يعني تصبح مساله الخروقات ورقه
بيدهم خاصه انه والسيد تابلر من واشنطن
اكيد بيعرف هي المساله اكثر مني انه في
خلاف شديد بين وزاره الدفاع وجهاز
الاستخبارات الامريكي المجلس مجلس الامن
القومي وبين وزاره الخارجيه اللي ممثلها
كيري بخصوص مساله التعاون مع الروس
بيشوفوا انه هذا يعني
اي يعني بادره او سابقه اي غير صحيحه
وخطره انه مهما كانت الاوضاع لا يمكن ان
نتعاون معهم لا هنا ولا في اماكن اخرى لان
التعاون هنا يمتد الىى سيمتد الى مناطق
اخرى وهذا تريده روسيا بشده هو هذا
الموضوع المتعلق المتعلق بالهد المتعلق
بال هدنه سيد سيد
العايد هناك ملحوظه ساقتها صحيفه
الاندبندنت
ربما تستحق وقفه الاندبندنت تقول وهنا
اسال السيد تابلر بعد اذنك
الاندبندنت تقول هذا الاتفاق هو انا اقتبس
هذا الاتفاق هو
نتيجه ميزان قوى جديد تبلور على الارض في
السنتين الماضيتين وبالتالي هو اتفاق لا
يرمي الى
محاوله حلحال الموقف بقدر ما يكرس وضعا
قائما على
الارض
اعتقد ان هناك رغبه في ايقاف الاعمال
العدائيه للحد
من حده النزاع ويك ان يكون هناك مجال للحل
السلمي لكن هل سيحدث هذا ام لا الامر لا
يبدو واضحا لكن حتى لو كان هناك رئيس
امريكي جديد في
الولا في يناير القادم فان الخيارات لهذا
الرئيس في سوريا لن تكون جيده بالمره
سيكون هناك اعاده تقيييم لكن هذا معني به
محاوله هذه المبادره لكن الجميع يعرفون ان
هذا بعيد التحقيق في
المستقبل وهناك محاوله
لتجميد النزاع حتى يمكن التعامل معه في
المستقبل انت هنا تتحدث عن خيارات الرئيس
الامريكي الجديد ولكننا سنتوقف بعد الفاصل
عن عند خيارات المعارضه السوريه في
التعامل مع هذه الهدنه نعود بعد
[موسيقى]
فاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نتحدث فيها عن الهدنه التي انطلقت في
سوريا ومدى قدرتها على الصمود
سيد عبد الناصر العايد في في باريس ما ما
الخيارات المطروحه الان امام المعارضه
عمليا للتعامل مع هذا الواقع الجديد الذي
تفرضه
الهدنه يبدو يبدو ان السيد عبد الناصر لا
يسمعني هل تسمعني الان سيد عبد
الناصر اسمعك اسمعك اكرر السؤال ما خيارات
المعارضه الان في التعامل مع هذه
الهدنه
اي بالتاكيد الانتباه لمساله انه عدم
استخدامها وسيله لتفريق صفوفها
ويعني ايجاد فتنه داخليه بينها لانه هذا
ما تعول عليه روسيا بالمرحله القادمه ايضا
وضع استراتيجيه صمود لمده الاشهر السته
القادمه
لانه هذه هي المده الزمنيه اللي راح يتم
اللعب فيها روسيا ومن النظام ومن ايران
باقصى الامكانيات للحصول على افضل ال
نتائج لانه هذه هي هي افضل شروط تحصل
عليها هذه القوى لذلك التحصن
ومحاوله الالتفاف الداخلي قدر الامكان على
بعضها البعض هو الحل الاستراتيجي الممكن
ايضا سيد العايد يعني احد القياديين
المسلحين في في المعارضه قال هذه الهدنه
هي ستتركنا نتقاتل فيما بيننا ويت ربع
الاسد على كرسيه ليتفرج علينا هل ممكن
تكون الصيغه بهذا الشكل
فعلا نعم احتمال كبير جدا يعني اللعبه
الامنيه الداخليه في هذا الموضوع واللي
تتعلق بعزل جبهه فتح الشام جبه النصره
سابقا ويجب ان لا ننسى جميعا انه الاتفاق
رغم كل ما عرض عنه يتضمن بنودا سريه نحن
لا لا نعرفها اعتقد انه هذه البنود تتعلق
بعلاقه هذه الفصائل وكيفيه يعني ان تحمي
نفسها من خلال علاقتها مع فتح الشام اي
حتى لو يعني تم يعني ابتعاد هذه الفصال عن
فتح الشام سيتم الطلب الى فصائل معينه
الابتعاد عن اخرى مثلا الجيش الحر عن
الاسلاميه وهكذا وصولا الى خلخله جبهه
الثوار بشكل عام وجعلها هشه ويمكن
اختراقها بسهوله هذا هدف رئيسي يجب ان
ينتبه له الجميع واعمل س سيتم عليه بزخم
كبير من قبل كما قلت الجهاز الامني للروس
والنظام و ويران و اعتقد انه الولايات
المتحده لن تقف عائقا في وجه هذا هذا
الامر الولايات المتحده الان سيد تابلر
تركز على
ضروره الفرز ان ان صح التعبير بين من
تسميهم بالمعارضه المعتدله ومن تسميهم بال
الجماعات الارهابيه وا المبعوث الامريكي
مايكل راتني حذر المعارضه من عواقب وخيمه
اذا هي لم تتعامل بشكل ايجابي مع هذه
الهدنه هل تعتقد بان واشنطن بهذا تج تضع
المعارضه في زاويه حاده وصعبه
للغايه واشنطن تضع المعارضه في في وضع
صعب فيما يتعلق
ب صعود جبهه فتح
الشام
ولكن بطبيعه الحال هناك قوه ثوريه كثيره
في
سوريا والنظام ايضا
نفسه ليس قويا جدا
لاستعاده مناطق في
البلد حتى لو استهدف فتح الشام هناك
الكثير من الامور غير
الواضحه وهذا يعني ان الولايات المتحده
وروسيا يرون فتح الشام كانه عدو
مشترك بينما المعارضه ترى الامر بخلاف ذلك
المعارضه ايضا سيد تابلر تعتقد بان واشنطن
وموسكو ليست من صفتين على الاطلاق تتحدث
عن فتح الشام او النصره سابقا على انها
تنظيم ارهابي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه نفس
الشيء بينما لا تشير باي كلمه لحزب الله
اللبناني او التنظيمات الاخرى التي تصنفها
ايضا واشنطن ارهابيه وتقف مع النظام والظا
وواشنطن لا تتحدث عنها
هذا صحيح لانه بالرغم من كون حزب الله
والمجموعات
الاخرى هي مجموعات
ارهابيه فانها لا تستهدف الولايات المتحده
الان
وتهاجم فقط تنظيم
الدوله لكن هذا الخلاف جدير بالاهتمام
لانه ان يترك القوى قوى الشيعه
ايضا وبدلا من ذلك تستهدف المجموعات
السنيه وهذا شيء جديد في المقاربه
الامريكيه لهذه المساله المعارضه السوريه
رغم الحذر الذي تبديه سيد عبد الناصر
العايد الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره يقول
بانه سيتعامل بايجابيه مع الهدنه
ويحتفظ بحق الدفاع عن النفس وعن الشعب اذا
كانت هناك خروقات هل تعتقد بانه قادر على
ان يتعامل ب بمرونه وذكاء مع هذه
الهدنه يعني هو مجبر على ان يكون كذلك
هناك مقتضيات دبلوماسيه وسياسيه لابد منها
لكن القول الفصل هو كما هو معروف يعني
للجميع هو للمقاتلين في الداخل يعني
بالمقابل يجب ان نرى انه يعني النظام
وروسيا وغيره كله يعلنوا موافقتهم لكنهم
بالمقابل يعملون على يعني مخططات اخرى
ايضا الثوار من حقهم وبعتقد انه لديهم
المرونه الكافيه والذكاء الاستراتيجي
للتعامل ومواجهه تهديدات اللي ينطوي عليها
هذا الاتفاق بما يلزم رغم كل الظروف
السلبيه الموجوده الحال الان على ساحه
الصراع اللي بتتمثل كما يعني اسلفنا بهذه
الرغبه الامريكيه باداره الصراع فقط و
بالانسحاب العربي انسحاب الطرف العربي
حاليا من المواجهه في سوريا سيد العايد
الخطه الان يفترض انه اذا صمد هذا الاتفاق
اتفاق الهدنه لمده اسبوع ستنسق موسكو
وواشنطن
وسينشي مركز مشترك لمحاربه الارهاب كما
يصفونه مركزين على تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
وجبهه فتح الشام جبهه النصره سابقا هل
تعتقد بان اذا وصلنا الى هذه النقطه ففي
النهايه ستزداد الامور سوءا في سوريا ع ان
تحسم بافاقوس
اي لا بالتاكيد هي يعني مساله كارثيه لانه
اللي ما اللي بيعرف خريطه التوزع القوى
بداخل سوريا بيعرف انه جبهه فتح الشام
يعني مشتبك عضويا مع كافه ال القوى وفي
موجوده في كافه المناطق يعني كما حدث منذ
يومين اعلنت عن معركه في اقصى الجنوب في
القنيطره هي وفصائل اخرى و يمتد هذا هذا
التواجد في في كافه انحاء سوريا وبالتالي
مساله يعني استباحه قصفها من سلاحي القوى
العظمى روسيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه يعني دمار ما
تبقى من البلد وتدمير ما تبقى من القوه
الثوريه لذلك المساله ندير شوم لكن انا
شخصيا لا اعتقد ان هذا سيحدث هذا قد هذا
سوف يبقى ورقه يعني ضغط امريكيه لابقاء
كما قلت التوازنات خصوصا في مدينه حلب
خاصه انه هناك خلاف داخل الاداره
الامريكيه بين الدفاع والخارجيه حول هذه
النقطه ولكن اذا سارت الامور بشكل جيد سيد
تابلر هل يمكن ان نصل الى لحظه يكون فيها
اصطفاف القوات الامريكيه مع القوات
الروسيه مع قوات الاسد ضد المعارضه
المسلحه التي لا يمكن لها ان تفرز
الارهابي من غير الارهابي حسب التصنيف
الامريكي لا نظام الاسد لن يكون مشاركا في
اي عمليات عسكريه تدعمها الولايات المتحده
وهذا ما ينص عليه هذا الاتفاق لكنها
نقطه جيده لان هناك
مجالات
المجموعات الارهابيه مخ ممزوجه مع
المعتدله كانها قطعه رخام ومن الصعب
التمييز بين
المجموعات
وستكون مهمه صعبه جدا انا متاكد من ذلك
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد اندرو تابلر كبير
الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات الشرق
الادنى من واشنطن وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
باريس عبد الناصر العايد الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
السوري في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
ن